we've got people in charge
so what are we at Conservation
International going to do
working to change
hang on jobs and livelihoods that
security
survive
what
give people the tools they need to
change their
[Music]
and the thought
stop the destruction
[Music]
okay our first guest is dr. M sanjayan
who's an environmental scientist
specializing in the role of conservation
and saving people in nature he serves as
conservation internationals
chief executive officer our other guest
is Harrison Ford who serves as vice
chairman of the board of Conservation
International he is strongly committed
to environmental concerns and has served
on the board of Conservation
International for decades please join me
in welcoming our special guests thank
you so much for coming all the way to
Stanford to talk to our students how
many of you are familiar with
Conservation International raise your
hand okay
only a few well this is an incredible
opportunity to educate everyone and I
think we're gonna have a really
meaningful discussion can you tell us a
little bit about the organization the
mission the vision you know why is this
organization been around for so long
Sanjay maybe do you want to say Harrison
you want to start I wouldn't know where
to finish sunjin sure is that a problem
that we need to solve maybe I'll try
okay so I just say Conservation
International has been around for about
30 years it's almost exactly 30 is a
little bit more than that and it was
founded on a very simple premise and
that is people need nature to thrive
that it's in your own enlightened
self-interest to protect these things
the land the water wildlife that
surround us because it ultimately
provides everything that we have from
your jobs to food to medicine to
virtually to air we breathe when people
ask me what's the mission of the
organization I usually just sort of cut
down to like one simple line which is we
try to protect that part of nature that
is of most value to people and it's
important that I balance that out where
that word that's the most importance to
people and if you ask the simple
question why why not just protect all of
nature I'd be fine with that first thing
would be fine with that
but it turns out that if you really want
conservation to stick if you want to
stick in faraway places that you may
never get to see like Liberia or
Suriname or Madagascar or Indonesia or
Brazil places that we work in then at
the end of the day when once our
attention shifts somewhere else we have
to have created some kind of virtuous
cycle that will allow that conservation
of nature to continue long after we're
gone and if people aren't involved in
that dialogue then it won't happen it
will always be an ish there will always
be a hobby there will always be
something that people who have will
participate in and people who don't
simply just don't have the opportunity
to so this this wonderful video is
really moving but it also points out
that there are a lot of people in very
powerful positions who aren't engaged in
this and in fact deny that this is a
problem or want to avoid it how do you
deal with that how do you deal with
solving this problem when there are
people who are really not engaged well
part of the part of the way of dealing
with it is is to create economic
alternatives to unsustainable
development that's one of the very
things we started with when I joined
Conservation International 30 years ago
we had a three to five million dollar
budget and we were picking up tagua nuts
which are palm nuts and selling them to
Patagonia to make buttons out of and we
were giving people an economic
alternative to unsustainable development
and that continues to be the model that
I think is is most most useful so people
who are involved in entrepreneurial
enterprises I think are a big part of
the solution to create new ways of
addressing the issues too
to take advantage of the technology to
create jobs and and a marketplace that
that helps affect the condition of
nature one of the things that's been
most fusible is the is a notion of
monetizing the services of nature
putting an actual value on them and
allowing that information to generate
change we can't provide for ourselves we
don't have the technology we don't have
the capital to provide for ourselves
what nature provides to us in its
healthy state clean water from from an
undisturbed watershed clean air which
we've got a very pressing need for
sources of food sources of pollination
all of these things are the services of
nature that we cannot afford as human
beings replicate for ourselves and there
are economic opportunities and and I'm
you know I'm delighted when I when I see
the amount of
I just I saw Al Gore two years ago at at
Ted in Vancouver and he was he gave a
talk ten years after his first talk he
talked about how the effects of climate
change the detrimental effects of
climate change had progressed even
faster than anticipated but an even
greater even more important than that
perhaps was the fact that the the costs
of alternative sources of energy had
come down much much more that that
while the degradation was going on at a
greater rate than thought the costs of
of alternative energy were becoming less
and less so there is great hope in
technology there is a great hope in in
the in the business model for change one
thing to that so I completely agree you
know look the folks right now I'd in
this country around the world we're
still in denial hope that's something
good to drink our are doing so willfully
there is probably a small percentage of
the population who somehow doesn't
really believe it but I think really
smart business people really smart
politicians really smart individuals
they are making a choice to ignore
what's right in front of them it is no
longer a question of you don't know it
just does not ring true to me and
everywhere around the world that I
travel I see leaders in business and
leaders in civil society and government
repeatedly you know emphasize this
message that the time is now sustainably
is a real issue we need to deal with
protection of nature's something we
really need to deal with this morning I
had breakfast with the president of Gaia
sorry the vice president of Guyana the
interesting guys indigenous leader
Guyana is a small country in South
America where 85% of the country is
forested and we're sitting right here
just very close to here and he looked at
the hills he's basically looking over at
so the hills that divide this area from
the coast sort of I'd say like Woodside
the hills above that he's like how is
all of that still green like you know
why isn't it all houses and I said it's
the watershed for San Francisco it was
like a light bulb going off in his head
because because that's exactly what
we're talking about in Guyana with him
but what was a light bulb for him is
that he just sort of thought look this
is the richest place on the planet you
can
imagine and even here people need an
economic incentive in order to protect
nature so we have a roomful of people
who are very entrepreneurial many of
these folks are gonna go out and start
companies how do you bake this type of
thinking into new ventures so that when
they get started this isn't something
that gets added in later and gets
something that baked in in the beginning
thinking about these things in the way
you manufacture the way you distribute
the types of products you you provide
the how do you do that is that something
that you spend time thinking about and
working on yeah well I think Walmart for
instance spent a lot of time thinking
about it and and changed their business
model significantly to to be able to
represent to their customers and to
their employees that they were doing
their part in creating sustainable
supply routes for the products that they
offered and I think that worked to their
advantage and it reduced their costs so
I mean there's one one example of a
comfortable company that that has made
real strides in that in that area great
and I know that there are lots of
stories I spent some time on your
website which was very impressive in
terms of the breadth and depth of the
types of things you're doing it would be
great if you could maybe share a couple
of stories of examples of this type of
transition and the type of levers that
you've been able to use in order to
effect change from the very beginning of
conservation international we we had on
our on our original board a man named
Chuck headland who was a was an
executive of Exxon oil we thought a lot
of the get of the concert
community resisted our working with
people in the extractive industries but
we worked with Exxon to improve their
their their practices in the field to
create a system of best practices which
not only helped protect the people who
were living close to their oil fields
and and the places where they were doing
their work but but made them more
attractive to their to their
shareholders and we thought that I mean
Conservation International was people
found that suspicious that we are
willing to work with with with business
what business had had really were
stepped up to the plate for us and and I
think our history with business has been
very very important yeah and generally
very positive yeah so having worked in
the it Conservation International been
involved for so long have you seen some
significant shifts in the way the
organization is looking at change and
the types of opportunities has there
been some insight that has led to
different types of programs well we
started out talking about biodiversity
and and migration pathways for animals
and and really we are our definition of
the work that that we need to do that
needs be done shifts from day to day we
really have found that our most
important product is is strategic
thinking ways of addressing the issues
that continue to crop up the ways to
manage
the available resources and to move
people to be to positively contribute to
the solutions for the environmental
problems that we have I mean I'd say
look we're relatively modest size
organization we're small enough to be
nimble but big enough to have an impact
at the scale of sales a country and if
you're in that space you want to be
either the first or you want to be the
last there's value to being both right
in terms of the cost of entry and the
impact you can have you know what a
couple of things that just in reflection
and so the questions are you asking
about enterpreneurship and how the
business when we started and I look I've
only been at CI for three years and I've
been the CEO for all of seven months and
that's a day-by-day Enterprise or who
will see how that goes but I'll say that
I've been in conservation for a long
time and the one thing I've noticed with
businesses is your business are doing it
because it it really is in their own
interest now sustainability equals
availability companies are no longer
doing it because of you know see us our
reasons right you're not doing it simply
to be a good player or a good actor it's
well beyond that right now so when we
started with Starbucks a company that if
you go into Starbucks pick up a bag
coffee look in the back you'll see our
logo on it that's a hard thing to do get
your logo onto something like so branded
like Starbucks right it happened over a
period of almost 20 years when we
started they had like 5% of their coffee
chain in a sustainable supply today it's
essentially a hundred percent so every
drop of coffee that you buy at Starbucks
basically comes from a farm we're
talking three hundred and fifty thousand
farmers in dozens of countries around
the world where you cannot cut a tree
down in order to grow coffee you have to
send your kid to school if you're going
to sell coffee to Starbucks and then a
variety of other metrics there including
you know pesticide use water use etc etc
now Starbucks is doing it partly to be a
good social citizen but they're doing it
also because genuinely there's
fundamental issues about land that is
available for coffee growing in a year
of climate change in a year o of rooms
dramatic change so it really is in their
own interest to be ahead of this and I
think Walmart and all the other
companies are doing that as well when CI
gets involved in a project for the most
part we're hopefully trying to be a
little disruptive we're kind of coming
at something and starting to ask a
question like how can we think about
this project in an entirely different
way and and sort of step back and see if
there's something fundamental we can
shake that can just tip the whole thing
over you know there's not a lot of value
in being you know a player that's just
going to do something that everyone else
is doing at least for our organization
of the scale that we work in so what
kind of levers do you view that you that
you have when you go into these
organizations or these whole systems
where are the places where you go okay
this is the if I push this button
something big is going to happen so can
I give one story so this is one of my
favorite stories about really an
innovative project that someone at CI
did so there's a woman named Sarah for Z
she works in a South Africa office she's
worked in this program for like 15 years
we're really trying to figure out
something a lot of Southern Africa
we're talking about in the maybe about
SWANA South Africa countries like that
are heavily fenced and the fences have
been put in sort of during colonialism
and then after that and it divides land
that you have cattle in and places that
you have wildlife in and the reason for
that is they want to keep cattle away
from wildlife because of transmission of
certain diseases like foot and mouth
disease foot and mouth disease won't
harm you or the meat you eat but it
couldn't in fact dairy production so
they want to keep them apart
now what started off as a kind of a good
idea of growing a cat local cattle
industry really had very perverse
incentives because what happened in
South Africa for example is that the
people who ended up with the land that
is disease-free tended to be either
white or privileged or somehow
politically connected and the people who
ended up with all that wildlife plan to
have cattle on tended to be mostly black
mostly indigenous mostly communities so
they have lots and lots of cattle but
absolutely no market for it just to put
this in perspective in a country like
Botswana you have 300,000 people
employed in the cattle industry 300,000
out of population 2 million of that only
700 700 out of 300,000 have access to
market so
this is a major problem so how do you
change that you can't talk to community
about grazing better or being more
wildlife friendly a chief tomy in South
Africa right in outside Kruger National
Park the premier wildlife destination
all of Africa said to me I will care
about your Rhinos when you care about my
cattle so the traditional model has been
trying to take these cows and doing some
sort of quarantine doesn't work for lots
of reason I can tell you later
so what our person did eventually is hit
upon him pretty brilliant idea
she created a mobile butcher shop a
mobile abattoir since of moving the
cattle to market she just brought the
market to the cows so she she built a
machine she built the whole thing you
know it's like state-of-the-art we have
the intellectual property on it she also
created an online auctioning system so
long story short if you go to Kruger
National Park right now you can go and
stay at $2,000 a night lodges owned by
people like Richard Branson there's a
fence right outside the fence is the
poorest black community in all of
Southern Africa right there right next
to this $2,000 a night fence those
community members for the first time
ever this summer were able to sell their
cows into the park for those lodges that
you stay in before that the meat was
coming from at least 200 miles away in
one case it was coming from Norway
imagine that you're importing beef from
Norway to feed tourists in a lodge on
this cow six kilometers away so it was
just this transformation that had major
social impact it's like it's subversive
what she did right
she created a system by which you can
bring that there and now we can actually
talk to this community now the community
actually is starting to ask okay I get
it I get why this park actually adds
value to my life because this thing that
I care so much about my cattle I can
actually sell I have a market for it so
you know innovation is not just in that
case there's engineering there is kind
of an online app that she created that
brings all the people together for the
right sale but it's also fundamentally
asking a question about justice and
society and asking what why is it this
way and how can we tip it what an
interesting story thank you
which is an amazing person at some point
I'm sure that there are so many stories
like that um in a few minutes I'm gonna
open it up to questions and we'll sort
of go back and forth with questions from
the audience and also questions for me
so start thinking about your burning
questions here that that was an
interesting story and I wonder how you
measure success okay because success in
the short run and the long run are
really interesting things in an
organization such as Conservation
International I'm sure you have some
metrics that you that you're you know
you've got some dashboard there you're
looking at and saying how are we how are
we doing against our goals I never well
enough so there continues to be a
struggle to perfect the models that we
that we have but metrics are very
important and and they need to be
transparent as well and that was a that
was a very important part of how we
organize our work right and a lot of a
lot of the work that's done through CI
is we pass through funds which we are
able to which we are able to get from
governments from international
institutions to people who are who have
a have a model of change and and but we
we are very concerned with the metrics
of measuring the effect of those things
and that's why when I talk about the
strategy of this organization it that's
a central focus for me absolutely
the there's a beautiful quote on the
wall somewhere on the floor around here
about you know the question that you ask
nature and and the answer that nature
gives back is sort of you know it's
measurement is that is this sort of the
answer that nature gives back you can't
ask the question if you don't have the
right measure set up for it it's a
massive challenge for every conservation
organization
it's easy in some ways to say I'm saving
this species or this place but the
minute you get beyond then you talk
about a whole river system or a whole
landscape or seascape becomes really
complicated so we have proximate metrics
of activity but then we also look at the
long attempt things which have to do
with both human wellbeing but also the
state of that ecosystem for me what I
use in some ways as a measure is I want
to ask myself is this project can this
project stand on its own feet even after
we're gone there is no pride in being in
a place for a very long time if you are
a non-profit because it your job should
be to put yourself out of a job in every
place you work and if you approach it in
that way
you're approaching it with a life cycle
of a project it means that within 10
years I want every project that we do to
essentially be self-sustaining
self-generating create a virtuous cycle
within that project now you might have
some level of plan to be in there but
philanthropy cannot be the driver of
that kind of persistent change there has
to be the kick in the ass to get things
going so how do you create a movement I
mean we were we were chatting about this
earlier you know are there any analogies
of other issues that have has been
really difficult to tackle and how what
can we learn from that Wow right now
there's a lot you go first because I
definitely have a feeling about this
well I have I have a lot of feelings and
it's very complex movements that we
spent a lot of time talking about
helping to create a movement for change
and it's the the the problem in my mind
is that movements are much more likely
to sell t-shirts than they are to make
change and and they very quickly shift
but it's very hard to to to use a
movement to create
these the specific kinds of activity
which are necessary to make the change I
mean but work but again we're seeing
today students of this High School in
Florida are making are in it are in a in
a in a position because of the the very
the feeling that is part of of their
dilemma part of what they're talking
about is so strong that emotionally that
it cuts across across a lot of a lot of
resistance and I'm seeing what I think
is a moment where we may begin to
address the issue of gun violence
because of the passion and that and the
immediacy of their of their access to
the means of communication and the way
we feel when we see these things I'm
very hopeful about that so do we have to
have situations like that with regard to
the environment to stimulate a movement
does it have to be a crisis it I I don't
know if it has to be but you know I I
the first time I came to America I was a
I don't know 12 years old and my parents
brought me here on a vacation and we
went to two places New York and Los
Angeles and that was my impression of
America and in the 80s which you know
made that that basically killed my
chance of coming to school in America
for my parents but it I distinctly
remember landing in Los Angeles and not
being able to see like any of the
buildings because of the pollution in
the air it was extraordinary and now you
fly in and on a routine basis and it's
completely different and if you fly to
go into China
you know this year I was just in Beijing
like a month ago it had unusual air
quality in terms of good air call you
could actually see the buildings across
the road and things like that because
they they've done a pretty intense
campaign
of Coal Fired sort of heating plants in
their houses I think if there's
something immediate like that you you
you know citizens in Delhi citizens in
Beijing are demanding change in terms of
air quality and I think it will happen
faster than we predict like it did in
Los Angeles when something like that
just seemed like just the way it was
ever always going to be but I think for
some of the other change that we talked
about you know what's happening to the
certification of the oceans or even
climate change in sort of that it's it's
harder I agree it it is a bit harder I
think you need some empathy and I think
you need I think you need people to be
able to see a pathway to make that
change real in their lives right because
I think despair alone won't get you
there you have to have some level of
shock or despair coupled with the
ability to actually do something about
it I think also I'm reminded of a
situation when I was trying to get my
parents to recycle years and years ago
and they thought I was very quaint that
I was recycling you know newspapers we
had newspapers in those days and until
the dump in their town got filled up and
they were getting charged lots of extra
money for having another garbage can and
guess what they started doing recycling
so that once they had a financial
incentive so I think you know you could
there'd people who are motivated for
very different things so do you think
about those different levels you know
the some people are gonna be motivated
by empathy and the long term vision and
those people who really it just has to
hit their pocketbook yeah no for sure
look I I protect nature because I just
love it you know I still hang on to a
little place in Montana because I like
going for a walk in the woods knowing
there's something bigger than me they
could jump out of the forest and bite my
head off
and it kind of works for me it just puts
a little bit of you know interest in all
our lives but that proposition save the
forest because it might kill you it's
just really not gonna work for the
majority of the planet so you know I
think you need to meet folks where they
are and you have to make whatever the
cause that you think is so important you
know how is it that Harrison and myself
and our board and some of my friends who
are in this audience are dedicating and
in might in my case and in many of our
cases a huge part of our lives
to this because we think it's so
important and yet so many people we see
feel like or seem like they're walking
around the world with blinders on right
and that strikes me it scares me and I
think it's part of it is has to do with
making it reasonable and interesting and
important to their life in something
that matters to them not in terms of
what matters to me I think the big
challenge of the environment were to be
honest is we've always been screaming
the message about why it's important to
whoever screaming that message as
opposed to meeting folks where they're
at
great so who gets the first question
back there will you stand up and speak
really loud
[Music]
thank you so much that was really very
moving so for those people who might be
listening on the podcast and didn't hear
she's from Costa Rica and was talking
about the impact that Conservation
International has had very specifically
on the country thank you so much but
Costa Rica hat is really a leader when
it comes to valuation of nature and
natural capital and they have been a
transformative nation a lot of ways we
bring people from Rwanda and from Kenya
and other countries to visit Costa Rica
to sort of learn about how Costa Rica is
really created a little bit of an
economy a green economy great did
someone else have a question
great over here please stand up so I'm
gonna repeat the question the question
is how do you implement these programs
with cultural sensitivity because you're
going into a place of the world that are
quite different than than where you may
come from well first of all we have
staff in those countries we don't impose
our ourselves only on these countries we
have people scientists people who work
in that country we have indigenous
people
who who have protected their part of
nature working with us and we're very
sensitive to local cultures and and the
importance of engaging people in in an
appropriate way
we don't work very much in the United
States except as as to influence the
policy of the United States government
to access the potential that the United
States government has to support
international conservation but we're but
in our in our field programs we do we
work with local local people and and in
Hawaii that's the one place that we do
have field presence a lot of that
program is with Hawaiian indigenous
Hawaiian communities so you know we have
pretty strong policies on you know prior
informed consent it kind of drives the
way in which we engage with communities
that's a policy for CI
we abide by it we're quite strict about
how that engagement happens most of our
staff are from the countries that we
work in as Harrison said and I think you
start the conversation by actually
asking folks what is it that you want
and it's surprising those answers tend
to be quiet straightforward and
something that virtually every one of
you will also understand great so we've
got a room filled with students from
across different disciplines lots of
engineering students if you're
engineering student raise your hand
great lots of engineering students what
about people from humanities who are in
the room great a lot of those anyone in
business business students okay they
didn't find their way across campus they
run over here okay a law students do we
have any lawyers in the room okay but
anyway we've got a really diverse group
how would you
lots of different types of Engineers
okay but these engineers want to change
the world okay we've got electrical
engineers the mechanical engineers and
computer scientists how would you
encourage them to think about the types
of things they can do here they are
looking and wanting to make an impact I
mean the students I meet are really
hungry to find ways that they can do
things that that have a positive impact
on the world look you're probably doing
what you're doing because at one point I
was doing exactly the same thing in that
you wanted to make a difference and I
think you know I think the awesome thing
about this is where as you start into
this career as you start into college is
starting to life in that sense you
really want to make a difference some
along the way that gets sort of you know
it falls to the wayside sometimes but
that's where you're starting from the
the field that you're choosing to
participate in in terms of engineering
and and I'm using that in the broadest
sense of the word is fundamental to the
way in which we will interact with the
natural world and with each other in the
future you just drive around here go
around the world you'll see that the
interesting thing about it is that this
technological revolution that is pretty
much impacted every field from
healthcare to transportation to how I do
my banking to you know online dating to
every field you can possibly think off
has not really had much of an impact
when it comes to conservation they've
been kind of like only two sort of
scientific sort of breakthroughs that I
can think of I can tell you what that is
later but you know I just don't see that
happen in my field yet what we're doing
is fundamental life on a the most
fundamental engineering problem that you
can really want to solve so I think
there's a huge scope and a huge
opportunity and opening for people who
understand science people who understand
engineering to apply that to
problems that have to do with the
natural world I'll give you one tiny
Xavier that example of the sort of more
you might not think a mobile butcher
shop is what you want to design
somewhere along your way but believe me
it was amazing what we came up with over
there but I'll give you a different kind
of project right so Philippines
Philippines the coast of Philippines was
kind of wiped out by a huge typhoon that
came through on Hainan came in three
years ago we went down there with
engineers from Bechtel who had a berth
tell its Bay Area company huge
engineering I think the second large
engineering company in the world
and we talked the community about what
we could do to prevent that happening
again and having this devastating impact
on the coastline and the engineers
wanted to build some form of seawall
some kind of structure engineered
solution to stopping a huge way the
conservationists we just wanted to plant
mangroves and coral reefs and so we
where the impasse then we talked to the
community and said how big were the
waves they pointed at the top of the
palm trees and both sides back tell guys
and our scientists realized that neither
of our solutions would work because at
that height no engineered hard structure
would have solved what was actually
coming so what they came up with is a
hybrid design that has some hard
engineered points but also has 400
meters of mangroves that have been
restored and a coral reef off shore and
working with scientists from MIT in this
case but we could have done it with
Stanford as well with the engineering
school right so we worked with there
with with students at MIT to really
model this out and they came up with
this solution that would actually serve
the the needs of that community but also
provide lots of services that's the
future and that green gray
infrastructure and that design I think
is what will ultimately save the
coastlines of the Philippines what's
interesting about that story is that it
also required engineers from lots of
different disciplines to work together
right this was not just
the mechanical engineer they needed to
have people who who understood all sorts
of other aspects of the environment to
be able to solve that problem anyway
yeah did you want to add something now I
think the other component was the that
this was these these potential solvers
of the problem were convened by an
organization that was bent on
conservation internet I mean that
conservation international organized
this unification of different
disciplines and that and that's part of
that's part of the the morality of our
of our work is that we're not just
focused on on what's happening in our
own backyard but where we understand
that what happens halfway around the
world has a great influence on us and
and that we we can't just work in our
own backyard
we can't just solve the nearest problems
we have to be available to bring
whatever resources we have to the rest
of the world it's also interesting is
that you work so closely with so many
other organizations right this is it
sounds as though you are supporting
other people who have problems that
they've identified in solutions that
they're that they want to implement what
are the sizes of those other
organizations are these lots of small
grassroots organizations that come to
you and say hey can you give me a few
thousand dollars or these you know
really big organizations so paint a
picture the type of groups that you work
with to actually implement these changes
sure so last year our budget was about
160 million dollars of which about 40
million went straight out to partners so
we take partnerships very seriously we
feel like it's the best way we can
increase our impact without growing our
organization we don't really have a
desire to make CI bigger we have a huge
desire to make our impact you know 10x
and so the way to do that is through
partnerships and those partnerships can
literally range from an indigenous
community
the working on one problem around
fisheries for example it involves a
dozen people to the government like
literally working with the state
government or with another conservation
organizing much bigger than us or the
World Bank so it can really sustain that
spectrum we have probably about 600
partners that we work with day after
tomorrow Harris and I and a few others
will sign a big partnership agreement
with NASA on some tools that we're
creating about predictive tools that
will help us map out degradation of land
around the world
added like 250 meter resolution which is
pretty good to get global coverage on so
the partnerships can range and and the
great thing about sea and it's fun
because one day you're literally talking
to one community in one village and the
next day you're engaging with you know a
university or a Beijing Academy of
Sciences or a national government we
found that the best solutions are
replicable they can make it they can be
tested in one place and refined in one
place but then they can be replicated in
other areas where the problem is the
same interesting is the will the same
group replicated or you say okay let's
write up a little case study and then
have another group take it to their
region I think what I'm talking about is
refining the process understanding the
the elements that that lead to the
problem and and finding a ways to a
solution in that been replicating you
that in another place and I'd be I'd
admit that we're not that great at
writing those things up so you know in
some ways we are a secret that and that
doesn't need to be a secret we've done
well with some things but I think the
the the sort of that need to solve the
next thing doesn't allow us often the
time and the opportunity which is really
important to reflect on it and be able
to you know case study it in that you
know in a way that can spread great
great No
can you please stand up do you have a
question you know look I think this this
question of external externalities is a
big one and in some cases we are able to
do that I'm not using pollution
specifically but in things like the use
of water or what happens to the product
after someone buys it right some time
ago we we got convinced by companies
that you know the disposability of of
something whatever we buy is our
responsibility and not theirs you know
that have you guys seen that like famous
like you know crying Indian commercial
that you always see on Earth Day if you
watch this this is like like embedded in
people I think in the 7th in our
generation go watches it's like look it
was like this commercial that basic it's
basically a Native American who actually
turns out to be actually I don't think
he was actually Native American I think
it was like an Italian actor but he's
going down this river and he sees
pollution he starts crying and it
convinced a lot of America to pick up
litter right it was the big first
littering anti-littering movement and to
be honest litter is pretty pretty low in
this country compared to lots of other
parts of the world that that often plays
like on Earth Day that was paid for
again the bottle that was actually I
nexi know who's doing this
that was paid for by the American
beverage industry it was very clever
they did it because I think they wanted
to shift the onus of responsibility from
people who are selling it the people who
are buying it they got all of a second's
to eat say this is our problem
we got to deal with it interesting so
you just started at Conservation
International no not too long ago and
have took the helm only a few months ago
you've been there 30 years let's flash
forward 20 years what's the organization
it'll look like what are the what are
the metrics you've hit what does success
look like 20 years down the line well 20
years down the line I will no longer be
involved with this organization
but there's a good chance that sunjin
might so I'll let you answer you haven't
seen Blade Runner or any of oh
you might be involved no okay 20 years
from now look I hope that more of you
are engaged with us I hope that we have
turned the tide on this deafening that
we hear sometimes from leaders in terms
of just not wanting to either believe
the data or believe the science and
we've sort of got beyond that point I
truly believe that we'll be in a place
where you know incentives technology
incentives and valuation of nature will
be built into the way we do our work
it's really hard to predict what's 20
years away I think of five years I can
sort of see that I honestly I
I promise you look I'm just gonna named
off for a second year but I was recently
with Gordon Moore who is a founding
board member at CI great friend of
Harrisons and Gordon you know I asked
him like did you ever see all of the
stuff that we can do with the chip he
said no we didn't when the furthest we
got was my son and I would walk around
the house and we'd point to things where
we thought a chip could go in we'd be
like the toaster we could put a chip in
there all of this this whole ecosystem
that was created was never in his mind
according to him so I find it very
difficult to sort of ask what is 20
years going to look like I will tell you
something if we don't take care of some
of these issues now by 20 years the cost
of doing so would be too great to really
handle the price of conservation never
gets cheaper in the future the cheapest
it's going to get today and we you and
us are the first generation that
actually knows what's coming around the
corner and so it really is in our own
best interest to do something about it
okay so my last question to both of you
is what I'd like to ask I'd like each of
you to go back a couple of decades to
visualize yourself when you were a
student in
and think about what you wish you knew
when you were 20 I was a desperately
poor student a very very difficult time
in my life and I regret deeply that I
didn't take advantage of the opportunity
this is what you might expect from your
elders son but it's true I didn't really
discover my utility in in college
towards the end of my college years I
began to understand that I had what I
what what moved me might be potentially
useful to me I found a community in
storytelling and that's what that's what
eventually became my life's work so
that's a that's a pretty short story
what when I was 20 I was trying to
convince my parents or fool them into
thinking that I was in med school when I
had really no intention of going that
route you know we when we would I grew
up in West Africa and my parents
encouraged my hobby which was a love for
nature and being outdoors and following
things around but they always saw it as
a hobby we'd get you know David
Attenborough's original life on that
series on like VHS tapes and I'd watch
that whole thing and I would you know
kind of say I want to do that and they'd
say quite literally that's for white
people in my language but that's what
they would say and you do find
encouraging it as hobby and and around
the age of 20 I started realizing that
there might be
something that I could do productively
to follow this passion that I was so
developing and kind of go into it all in
so it was a it was a really interesting
time where I was like literally like
taking classes just to send those grades
in and then just go do something else
what I would do differently if I could
go back and do it again you know I would
pick I pay a lot more attention to
college guarantee you that right like
it's just amazing how little like I
actually got out of like 20-something
years of education I could do that today
in like a year like all of that you can
actually do like I can't understand what
I spend all my time doing right you're
amazing
so but here's what some things I would
have done a little differently
Communications so like kind of Harrison
said obviously he went about that in a
very different and profound way being
able to tell a story is a really
important thing for an intrapreneur to
have and if you see some of the people
particularly around here who've made
these amazing changes and have convinced
you that you could do something that no
one else could it's true that power of
communication I'd have taken it more
formally I learnt it just accidentally
but that would have been something I
would have done more I would have
probably gone harder into statistics
because understanding it helps you
understand the world in a very unique
way and then I probably would have well
those are the two things I would really
lean in heavy on the stats I'd out of
lean in very heavily on the calm side
writing or speaking or whatever you take
don't underestimate how powerful that is
even maybe especially for engineers well
thank you so much for sharing your
stories with us this was really powerful
[Applause]
you